pas devoir vis-à-vis des français
vis-à-vis de la france c'est de faire
évoluer notre système de retraite ce qui
se passe dans la rue plus que nous
sommes capables de faire nous mêmes ça
peut encore amener le gouvernement à
réfléchir
c'est donc une détermination de ce
mouvement qui se confirme
notre devoir c'est d'agir d'agir dans
l'intérêt général
quand les salariés ne travaillent pas
l'économie ne tombe pas pour l'adoption
177 contre 151
le sénat a adopté retour sur la réforme
des retraites ce soir à 22h30 sur public
sénat
bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
sur public sénat à suivre ce matin sur
notre antenne à les travaux de la
commission des finances du sénat les
sénateurs ont auditionné début mars jean
françois vilotte président de l'arjel
il s'agit de l'autorité de régulation
des jeux en ligne
objectif de cette audition faire un
premier bilan un an après l'adoption
définitive par le parlement du projet de
loi relatif à l'ouverture à la
concurrence du secteur des jeux en ligne
bonne matinée à tous nous accueillons ce
matin monsieur jean françois vilotte
président de l'autorité de régulation
des jeux en ligne l'arjel
la loi relative à l'ouverture à la
concurrence et à la régulation du
secteur des jeux d'argent et de hasard
en ligne a été promulguée le 12 mai 2010
juste à temps pour permettre gré les
premiers opérateurs de paris avant la
coupe du monde de football elle
procédait d'une volonté pragmatique de
mieux encadrer l'offre de jeu en ligne
en légalisant certains sites selon un
cahier des charges strict est très
étoffé une nouvelle autorité
administrative indépendante dédiée a
ainsi été mise en place
l'arjel dont l'organisation est proche
de celle de l'autorité des marchés
financiers elle instruit les demandes
d'agrément
elle contrôle et le cas échéant
sanctionne les opérateurs autorisés et
participe à la lutte contre les sites
illégaux et la fraude
et bien que le nouveau marché des jeux
en ligne ne soit pas l'eldorado espéré
possible que les performances de
l'équipe de france de football n'ont pas
été l'accélérateur qu'avait imaginé
certains peut-être 1 et ont quelque peu
fantasmé tant en termes de volume de
mise
de rentabilité l'arjel a été d'emblée
confrontée à de nombreux défis
techniques économiques et juridiques
elle a dû assurer sa crédibilité en un
temps très court
elle a ainsi accordé une cinquantaine
d'agrément dans les trois catégories de
jeux et paris ouvert à la concurrence
les paris sportifs les paris hippiques
et le poker
l'arjel occupe assurément une place
centrale dans le dispositif et est un
acteur et un observateur privilégié de
l'évolution de ce nouveau marché
l'article 69 de la loi promulguée le 12
mai prévoit une clause de rentrer et un
rapport d'évaluation du gouvernement
dix-huit mois à compter de sa date
d'entrée en vigueur soit à la mi
novembre de cette année sans attendre ce
rapport nous sommes fondés à tirer notre
propre bilan et notre collègue françois
trucy qui a heureusement repris du
service pour effectuer un important
travail de suivi l'audition
d'aujourd'hui doit donc nous éclairer
sur l'activité de l'arjel durant ces
neuf mois d'ouverture du marché doit
nous permettre d'évaluer si la démarche
de l'égalisation constitue ou non un
succès et d'apprécier certains enjeux
tels que les nouveaux risques
d'addiction tels que la sécurité
informatique tels que l'intégrité des
paris hippiques et sportifs ou l'équité
de la concurrence entre opérateurs
historiques et nouveaux entrants
monsieur jean françois vilotte pourrait
débuter son audition si le veut bien par
un propos liminaire qui lui permettra de
dresser un premier bilan de son action à
la tête de l'arjel et puis je passerai
la parole aura porte en général au
rapporteur de la loi françois trucy et à
chacun d'entre vous si vous le souhaitez
mes chers collègues sur villote monsieur
le président nous vous écoutons
merci monsieur le président depuis la
création de l'autorité de régulation des
jeux en ligne
cette dernière a délivré 49 agrément à
36 opérateurs personne morale différente
au 24 février 35 opérateurs sont
titulaires de 48 agréments un agrément
et ont fait l'objet d'une abrogation et
cinq demandes d'agrément ont été
rejetées il y a aujourd'hui encore un
certain nombre de demandes d'agrément
dans les trois catégories ouvertes à la
concurrence qui sont encore en
instruction 25 agréments ont été
délivrés pour les jeux de cercles 15
agréments ont été délivrés pour les
paris sportifs
huit l'ont été pour les paris hippiques
le siège social d opérateur agréé pour
25 d'entre eux ces sièges sont localisés
en france 8 à malte 1 en irlande 1 au
royaume uni les maisons mères des
opérateurs agréés sont localisés pour 19
d'entre elles en france 7 à malte 1 une
au luxembourg 3 au royaume uni une en
irlande une en grèce et trois en italie
voilà la localisation des maison mère et
des filiales qui ont fait l'objet d'un
agrément à malte il ya une culture
particulière
la culture tient au régime qui a été de
délivrance d'agrément qui a été mis en
place par les autorités maltaises très
attractif parce que les autorités
maltaises souhaitait attirer des emplois
et de la fiscalité
ceci étant cette stratégie de régulation
a été un petit peu freiné par la
jurisprudence maintenant constante de la
cour qui a clairement indiqué qu'il n'y
avait pas et qu'il n'y aurait pas à
court ou moyen terme de reconnaissance
automatique d agrément délivré par un
état européen et que cet agrément
n'emporterait pas comme conséquence la
possibilité de prester dans les autres
états européens
donc les lélés les territoires où état
comme gibraltar comme malte qui ou les
îles anglo normandes qui avait fondé une
stratégie de régulation pour attirer des
emplois de la fiscalité
manifestement pas pour que les
opérateurs preste sur le marché
domestique de gibraltar ou ou d'alderney
cette stratégie de régulation a connu un
coup d'arrêt avec la jurisprudence de la
cour
les chiffres que je vous ai indiqué 49
agrément 36 opérateurs peuvent être
comparés au niveau européen par exemple
avec la situation italienne où il y à 60
opérateurs le marché étant ouvert depuis
2006 donc il y a des chiffres qui sont à
peu près de 2 de même ordre de grandeur
l'arjel en ce qui la concerne
ne
et forte aujourd'hui d'une cinquantaine
d'agents 45% d'entre eux exerçant des
fonctions le contrôle au sein de la
direction des enquêtes et des contrôles
ou de la direction des services
informatiques le collège de l'arjel
s'est réuni 22 fois depuis la création
de l'autorité de régulation
trois commissions spécialisées comme la
loi l'y autorise ont été créés au sein
de l'arjel l'une a pour objet d'étudier
l'impact de l'ouverture sur la demande
aussi bien quantitative que qualitative
ou qu'en relation ou en relation avec
les phénomènes d'addiction
une commission spécialisée le suit les
questions d'impact de l'ouverture sur
les filières notamment sous l'angle
économique mais également sous l'angle
éthique la préservation de l'éthique des
compétitions sur lesquelles des paris
sont sont proposés et une troisième
commission a été créée pour évaluer dans
la perspective de la clause de revoyure
et l'efficacité des instruments et
procédures de régulation dont l'autorité
dispose l'autorité a travaillé en
relation très étroite avec trois autres
autorités indépendantes
l'autorité de la concurrence l'arjel
n'étant pas une de concurrence donc nous
est souvent jouons avec l'autorité de la
concurrence dans un cadre d'ailleurs que
que la loi prévoit et l'autorité de la
concurrence s'est autosaisie des
questions de l'ouverture de ce marché
le csa qui a pour mission d'encadrer la
publicité susceptibles d'être faite au
bénéfice des sites agréés et la cnil
puisqu'il y a un certain nombre de
sujets communs autour de l'utilisation
des données qui sont captés et et
archiver et auquel l'arjel peut te
accéder au 31 décembre 2010 448 millions
d'euros de mises avait été enregistrée
sur le marché des paris sportifs 452
millions de mises
en paris hippiques 3 milliards 705
millions d'euros de mises en poker sous
la forme du cash games et ce jeu de
poker à la table duquel on peut entrer
et sortir à tout moment et 412 millions
d'euros de droits d'entrée au poker sur
la forme de tournoi ces chiffres sont
des chiffres de mises
c'est important parce qu'il ne
correspond pas ils ne correspondent pas
à la dépense réelle des joueurs s'est
mise étant constitué de dépôt mais
également de gains recyclés et
j'évoquerai le taux de recyclage dans un
instant qui différencie naturellement
très nettement le poker des paris
sportifs ou les paris hippiques ce qui
explique d'ailleurs des fiscalités très
différenciée aller sur sur cheveux ce
point les chiffres que vous avez cités
440 millions quatre cent cinquante deux
et puis 4 milliards cent sont 17
c'est le montant des jeux le montant des
mises puisque l'assiette fiscale ce sont
les mises
oui il donc les chiffres que je vous
communique correspondent à l'assiette
fiscale la gabegie slater ha ha ha
prévus
à quand donc ce sont les mises et donc
un gain qui est rejouée devient une mise
qui est fiscalisé bien sûr d'où le les
taux de recyclage très différenciée d'un
segment de jeu à l'autre qui explique
ces chiffres très très différents les
miss ont naturellement à distinguer du
produit brut des jeux le produit brut
des jeux
ce sont les mises - les gains se produit
brut des jeux pour les sites de paris
sportifs
cet élu pardon à 79 millions d'euros en
paris hippiques à 98 millions d'euros
1,6 et en poker à 139 millions d'euros
de pbj il y a eu près de 3 millions de
comptes joueurs ouverts auprès des
opérateurs légaux sur ses près de trois
millions deux millions 900 mille très
exactement 1 million cinq sont devenus
des comptes définitifs
un million quatre et tente soit à la
date de ce bilan des comptes provisoires
soit ce sont des comptes dans l'activité
a été suspendue faute de la part du
joueur d'avoir transmis un certain
nombre de renseignements et de pièces
exigées par la loi pour s'assurer
notamment de l'âge du joueur et de
l'identité du titulaire du compte de
paiement
il y a deux millions de comptes joueurs
qui ont été actifs c'est à dire qu'ils
ont réellement enregistrée après lourdes
leur ouverture enregistrer une
transaction de de jeu le nombre de
comptes joueurs moyen par joueur ce qui
est une donnée importante en matière
d'addiction puisqu'on peut ouvrir un
compte joueur auprès de plusieurs
opérateurs ce nom de comptes de joueurs
moyen par joueur et de 1,43 vers
l'immense majorité des joueurs ont
seulement un compte joueur
une petite frange d'entre eux sont
titulaires d'un nombre important de
comptes joueurs et la moyenne est à 1,4
les mise moyenne par pari par paris
unitaires ont été de 7,7 euros 50 par
paris sportifs est de 4 euros vers gul
un art paris en paris hippiques donc un
montant unitaire de paris sportifs plus
élevé que le montant unitaire de paris
hippiques mais une fréquence de jeu en
paris hippiques plus élevé qu'en matière
de paris sportifs
ce qui fait que la des plats les mise
moyenne hebdomadaire par joueur actif en
paris hippiques
ces mises se sont élevées à 130 euros
quand ils se sont élevés à 110 euros
pour les paris sportifs paris unitaires
plus faibles dans les peas mais des
joueurs qui jouent plus souvent et plus
régulièrement
s'agissant du taux de recyclage que
j'évoquais à l'instant le seul président
1 euro déposé que sur un compte joueur
génère en moyenne 4 euros de mise en
paris sportifs
3 euros verville 2 de mise en paris
hippiques 23 euros de mise
en poker sous la forme de cash game et 8
euros de droit d'entrée en poker sur la
forme de tournoi donc on voit
l'importance du recyclage des gains
immédiats dans la forme de jeu qu'est le
poker qu'est le cash game
le taux de retour aux joueurs intégrant
comme le législateur l'a décidé les
bonus reversés aux joueurs qui sont des
bonus versés volontairement c'est
important quand on évoquera le modèle
économique par les sites aux joueurs ce
trj s'élève à 85 % en matière de paris
sportifs donc on voit que c'est un
secteur extrêmement concurrentiel et il
y a eu une concurrence entre les sites
qui se sont alignés sur le trj plafonné
de 85% 80% paris hippiques
c'est de notre point de vue les faits de
la moindre concurrence sur le secteur
hippique et donc l'opérateur le plus
important influent sur cette moyenne de
trj à la baisse
80 % paris hippiques
s'agissant du poker je rappelle qu'il
n'y a pas de plafonnement de ce terreau
j il a été de 94 % constatée en 2010
pour les tournois et de 98% sous la
forme du poker cash game donc
il s'agit de du trj la politique de
bonus qui est donc intégré haute énergie
mais qui est distinct puisque c'est une
décision de stratégie marketing de la
part des opérateurs 61 millions d'euros
de bonus ont été distribués aux joueurs
en 2010 14 millions en paris sportifs
36 millions en jeux de cercle et 11
millions trois cent mille euros en paris
hippiques
toujours pour donner des chiffres un peu
consolidé
si l'on applique aux montants des mini
ce que j'ai indiqué les pourcentages de
prélèvements obligatoires que le
législateur a décidé le produit de ces
prélèvements obligatoires hors tva qui
devrait être naturellement constaté ils
sont des jeux et paris en ligne devrait
s'élever pour l'année 2010 pour la
période de mai à décembre devrait
s'élever à 124 millions d'euros 39
millions d'euros de prélèvements par
ipic
ça représente 8,8 pour cent des miss et
7,5 plus les 1,3 qui sont prévues au
bénéfice du centre national de
développement du sport 40 millions 20,5
en cash game
ça représente 1,1 pour cent des mises
car je vous rappelle que ces 2 % des
mises plafonné à 1 euro la donne donc la
moyenne de prélèvement sur les mises est
inférieure à 2%
s'agissant des tournois 2 % de droits
d'entrée 8 millions 2 s'agissant des
paris hippiques
il est là
fait masse de 2 8% qui on est et qui
sont devenus une fiscalité non affectés
et les 6,4 pour cent de fiscalité d'état
les prélèvements s'élève s'élèveront
devrait s'élever à 66 millions d'euros
si je quitte le domaine des prélèvements
obligatoires monsieur le président pour
aborder la question du droit au pari
dont l'assiette et sont les événements
organisés en france les événements
sportifs organisés en france
ce droit au pari a produit comme
recettes commerciales au bénéfice des
organisateurs cinq cent trente mille
euros 105 130000 euros en 2010 et la
projection annuelle est de l'ordre d'un
million d'euros de droits aux paris qui
reviendrait aux organisateurs
d'événements en france pourquoi ce
chiffre relativement bas
parce que comme je viens de le souligner
l'assiette de ce droit paris ce sont les
paris enregistré sur d organiser des
événements organisés en france
or les événements support de paris
organisé en france ne représente que 15%
du montant des paris enregistrés de
france ce qui veut dire que l'essentiel
des mises et enregistrés sont heureuses
est enregistrée sur des compétitions
organisées à l'étranger et par exemple
si on prend l'exemple du football la
ligue 1 et la ligue 2 de football ne
représente qu'un quart des mises
football donc l'essentiel des miss sont
enregistrées sur des championnats
étrangers ou des compétitions
européennes les trois secteurs paris
sportifs paris hippiques jeux de cercles
se comporte à court terme je ne fais pas
de projection définitive à long terme
est ce ces trois marchés apparaissent
relativement distincts les uns des
autres les le pari hippique est un pari
extrêmement régulier croissant sur
internet non dépendant des fluctuations
des paris sportifs ce qui veut dire que
les semaines où on parie peu sur le
sport on ne parie pas davantage sur
l'hippisme et inversement quand on parie
beaucoup sur le sport on ne parie pas
moins sûr l'hippisme donc il apparaît à
court terme en tout cas que ce sont des
marchés distincts
s'agissant des jeux de cercle le poker
c'est un marché extrêmement dynamique
on le voit
à l'analyse du montant diniz avec un
nombre de joueurs importants la moitié
des joueurs jouent au poker et c'est un
marché qui est en croissance régulière
donc c'est une courbe ascendante on
s'aperçoit également que toujours à
court terme le développement de
l'activité des jeux en ligne n'a pas eu
d'effet baissier négatif sur les jeux en
dur que ce soit les jeux de la française
des jeux en dur les paris sportifs en
dur de la française des jeux ont
augmenté de 42%
les jeux de grattage et de loterie en
ligne ont progressé de 6% en 2010 et
s'agissant des paris hippiques les paris
hippiques en dur sont restés stables en
2010 quand l'activité en ligne du pmu a
progressé de 9,4 pour cent donc pas
d'effets négatifs sur les paris en dur
pas d' effet de cannibalisation des
paris hippiques par le sportif pas
d'effet sur à ce stade à court terme sur
les paris en dur
s'agissant du but du sport je voudrais
simplement vous je vous indiquer que la
part du football dans les paris sportifs
qui était attendu à un niveau élevé
fort de ce qui est constaté à l'étranger
se révèle beaucoup moins importante que
prévu elle tourne autour de 55 % du
montant des mises
quand le football représente 92% des
mises en italie par exemple sur la
période courte du 1er janvier au 20
février
nous avons une amplification des
tendances que nous avions observée sur
l'année 2010
du 1er janvier au 20 février le montant
des mises paris sportifs s'est élevé à
93 millions d'euros
quand il s'est élevé à 144 millions
d'euros en paris hippiques donc il ya un
décrochage du sportif par rapport à
l'hippisme je reviendrai sur les raisons
de ce décrochage 1 milliards 150
millions d'euros en poker sous la forme
de cash game donc nous avons bien une
tendance haussière et 162 millions
d'euros en poker sous la forme de
tournoi s'agissant de la baisse des
paris sportifs en 2010 le marché s'est
ouvert vous l'avez rappelé monsieur le
président avec la coupe du monde de
football qui a eu un effet immédiat et
important sur le volume des paris
sportifs la semaine où le montant
maximum de mises de paris sportifs a été
enregistré a été celle de l'élimination
de la coupe de la de l'équipe de france
de la coupe du monde de football depuis
le football est rentré dans une forme de
dépression en matière de paris sportifs
dont il ne s'est jamais totalement
relevé
et d'ailleurs nous constatons que le
marché des paris sportifs est un marché
de passionnés de sport très dépendant de
l'offre des événements et c'est un
marché de supporters ceux qui d'une d'un
certain point de vue est prise en compte
par les opérateurs et et le fait que
l'équipe de france soit battue est
plutôt une bonne affaire pour les
opérateurs puisque les passionnés et les
supporters vote quelle que soit la
rationalité 2 2 lors de leur pari pour
sur une victoire il avait souhaité jouer
l'équipe de france est par contre ce que
nous avons constaté à la fin du premier
du du dernier trimestre de l'année 2010
et ça c'est un phénomène important est
spécifique aux paris sportifs qui sont
les seuls paris à cote
c'est que pour tenir le plafonnement du
trj imposer le légine par le législateur
à 85%
les opérateurs ont dû très
significativement dégradé leur cote pour
tenir un trj en paris à cotes fixes
c'est un art beaucoup plus subtil qu'on
pari mutuel ou quand poker c'est l'art
de la cote
il faut donc c'est difficile à tenir ce
qu'il faut pour arriver à attraper un
trj au dessus de la moyenne autorisée
il faut considérablement dégradé la cote
et quand on dégrade considérablement la
cote
on diminue très significativement
l'intérêt de 2,2 de parier est ce que
nous avons constaté c'est qu'une
diminution du trj par cet effet de
détérioration de la cote de 2 ou 3
points
un effet volume sur le montant des paris
de l'ordre de 20%
donc cette année les victoires du pardon
je ne suis pas ce jeu je pense que le
paris à cotes fixes est quelque chose
qui si l'on combine une fiscalité assise
sur les mises dans les mises en paris à
cotes fixes ne signifie pas grand chose
parce que vous pouvez avoir un volume de
mises important et un produit brut des
jeux négatif si les parieurs sont plus
intelligents que le site donc la
fiscalité est alors à ce moment là un
phénomène aggravant pour pour
l'opérateur
donc les le paris à cotes fixes
cohabitent assez mal avec une fiscalité
assise sur les mises avec un
plafonnement contrôler chaque trimestre
du taux de retour joueurs
voilà donc pourquoi c'est important
parce que quand on constate une
diminution du volume des mises de paris
sportifs
on peut avoir une lecture optimiste qui
consiste sa faune c'est que après tout
c'est plutôt vertueuse à limite les
risques d'addiction il n'est pas
souhaitable d'augmenter
à l'infini le montant des mises vous
pouvez avoir aussi c'est la vision
optimiste
une remise en cause de l'objectif
poursuivi par le législateur qui était
de faire basculer une demande qui est
est orienté vers les sites illégaux de
la faire basculer sur les sites légaux
et la première le premier argument de
basculement c'est l'acte réactivité des
sites légaux qui sont contrôlés réguler
transparent qui mettent en place des
dispositifs de lutte contre l'addiction
donc toute la question est de savoir que
sont devenus ces mises qui n'ont plus
été enregistrés sur les sites légaux en
raison de la détérioration des cop si
ils attendent des jours meilleurs tant
mieux si par des stratégies
intentionnelle le contournement de la
loi
ils sont repartis sur des 6es ego danger
donc c'est un point d'équilibré et et
donc la rentabilité des opérateurs dit
autrement l'attractivité des sites est
un élément qui est important alors un
mot de la rentabilité des opérateurs
d'abord tous les opérateurs en 2010 ont
perdu de l'argent
quels que soient les secteurs et ça
n'est pas tout à fait anormal puisque
pour l'essentiel d'entre eux ils
l'avaient prévu
il avait prévu parce que s'agissant d'un
marché qui s'ouvrait à la concurrence il
avait prévu dans leurs business plans de
consacrer des montants importants à
leurs stratégies publicitaires et
marketing
donc cette somme tout quelque chose
d'eux qu'ils attendaient qui était
attendu et qui ne doit pas
nécessairement remettre en cause le
modèle économique je dis bien pas
nécessairement ensuite la question c'est
de savoir si les dépenses marketing et
publicitaires des sites qui devront
naturellement pour que ces sites ne perd
le plus d'argent être
très significativement diminué est ce
que cette diminution massive leurs
dépenses publicitaires et marketing est
compatible avec l'effet d'attractivité
qui est recherché par le législateur
c'est tout le problème de la recherche
du point d'équilibré de la loi en
matière de lutte contre les sites
illégaux
je rappelle qu'il ya des moyens par
ailleurs civile pedneault sur lesquelles
je reviendrai mais qui sont efficaces
que s'ils ne s'applique qu'à une offre
illégale devenu marginal
donc c'est un sujet important
les dépenses marketing ainsi que les
bonus se sont élevées à 214 millions
d'euros tous opérateurs confondus en
2010 74 millions d'euros en paris
sportifs ce qui représente 94 % du
produit brut des jeux
donc évidemment quand on consomme 94 %
de son produit brut
on ne peut pas espérer ne pas perdre
d'argent en poker 70 pour 77 % du pbj
108 millions d'euros et en paris
hippiques 32 millions 32 % du pbj
je rappelle que la grosse différence
sont sans porter de jugement
c'est le degré moindre de concurrence
sur le marché hippiques sur le marché
les paris sportifs d'où les chiffres
très différents de stratégie
publicitaire et marketing
si l'on ajoute à ces pourcentages du pbj
que représentent les dépenses marketing
le pourcentage que représente la
fiscalité hors tva la fiscalité paris
sportifs représentent 50 % du pbj la
fiscalité poker représente 35 % du pbj
la fiscalité hippiques représente 72 %
du pbj
les frais de structure constaté moyen
des opérateurs représentent de l'ordre
de 30 à 40 % du pbj pour les opérateurs
notamment de paris sportifs et des
opérateurs de poker
donc on voit bien évidemment que dans
ces conditions
l'activité est nécessairement
déficitaire dans les perspectives 2011
les business plans et le réajustement de
leur stratégie de dépenses marketing
seule l'activité poker en 2011
atteindrait un niveau de rentabilité
positif donc l'enjeu notamment dans le
cadre de la clause de revoyure
c'est de suivre de très près cette
question du modèle économique des
opérateurs
si l'on veut rechercher si l'on veut
atteindre le point d'équilibré que
j'évoquais à l'instant
or naturellement les trois facteurs
d'ajustement de recherche de ce point
d'équilibré
c'est la diminution évidemment des frais
marketing et publicitaires mais jusqu'à
quel niveau pour que les sites demeurent
attractifs
c'est la question éventuelle de la
fiscalité assiette ou tôt et c'est la
question du terme à ce stade
l'autorité de régulation se garderait
bien de tirer des conséquences de ce que
je viens de vous dire définitive mais il
nous paraissait important de l'évoquer
devant vous aujourd'hui parce qu'il me
semble que c'est un c'est un débat qui
sera évidemment récurrent pendant
la clause de revoyure les prélèvements
obligatoires jeu je les ai évoqué je me
tiens à votre disposition pour les
détails et je crois faisant le propos
improductif c'est peut-être pas
nécessaire simplement pour vous dire que
le législateur et créer une nouvelle
source de financement pour les communes
abritant un ou plusieurs hippodrome
étant donné le volume des mises en paris
hippiques en ligne ce financement des
voeux devrait s'élever à environ 10
millions d'euros en 2010
le législateur avait également prévu une
nouvelle source de financement pour les
communes abritant un ou plusieurs
casinos le montant affecté à ces
communes
compte tenu des chiffres que j'ai évoqué
devrait est susceptible d'être estimé
aux alentours de 6 millions six cent
mille euros en 2010
donc ce début d'étape je t'ai vous a
porté sur la fiscalité
bon les villes et qui bénéficient de ces
contributions sur 2010 ce sera versée à
quel moment en 2011 pour les villes
casino également monsieur le président
je n'en sais rien parce que là c'est un
sujet qui échappe totalement à
l'autorité de régulation ce que la loi
prévoit c'est que ce produit à
concurrence de 15 % dans la limite
chaque année à 10 millions donc là pour
les casinos on est un peu en deçà est
affecté aux communes on le ressort
territorial desquels sont ouverts au
public et c'est donc c'est ce que dit la
loi c'est que versés en 2011 c'est ce
qui correspond aux jeux de 2010 où je
pense que ce qui sera versée en deux
millions c'est ce qui cause mais ça
c'est une question à poser une
administration fiscale s'étaient mis
d'accord
un mot de la question de l'intégrité des
compétitions sportives
c'est pour moi un sujet absolument
essentiel pour le sport comme ça l'est
naturellement pour l'hippisme dans son
domaine s'agissant du sport je crois
qu'un
il ya il faut bien avoir en tête que le
rôle de l'autorité de régulation en
l'état c'est de contrôler l'activité des
sites agréés en france et donc de
protéger le consommateur sur le marché
domestique français et donc nous ne nous
intéressons en tant qu autorité de
régulation co paris enregistré 2 france
et à la lutte contre les sites illégaux
contrôle de des opérateurs agréés dans
ce cas par contre l' atteinte à la
sincérité des compétitions sportives
organisées en france peut avoir pour
origine des paris enregistrés hors de
france donc c'est un sujet qui doit
nécessairement avoir des prolongements
internationaux c'est la raison pour
laquelle le conseil de l'europe s'en est
occupé en 2010 ensemble ont longtemps
continué à s'en occuper en 2011
en votant des recommandations à ses
états membres et en 2012 en mettant en
chantier un instrument conventionnel
c'est la raison pour laquelle le
commissaire au marché intérieur dans la
publication de son livre vert sous forme
de questions se préoccupera de ce sujet
c'est la raison pour laquelle la
commissaire vassiliou au titre de ses
missions incluant le sport a évoqué
cette question
c'est aussi la raison pour laquelle le
seuil où commence à se mouvoir sur cette
question pour que le sport
internationale s'organise dans la loi
française y insérant des dispositions de
prévention des risques qui sont des
dispositions tout à fait vertueuse
d'abord nous avons limité la possibilité
de paris en limitant la liste des
événements limitant la liste des
éléments de ce corps et de phases de jeu
ce qui a un effet d'ailleurs sur l'offre
et donc sur le volume des paris sportifs
il n'y a que 30 sport aujourd'hui
autorisés aux paris sportifs et nous
avons des éléments de ce corps des
phases de jeu qui sont beaucoup plus
restreinte restera que ce qui existe
dans l'offre étrangère
il existe un droit d'exploitation
reconnu aux organisateurs d'événements
en france nous avons eu à connaître de
29 projets de contrats de
commercialisation de ce droit depuis
l'ouverture du marché
le montant moyen des droits a été
fixer aux armes par le marché pardon aux
alentours de 1% des mises le montant
produit par ce droit je l'évoquais tout
à l'heure 530 mille euros la loi
également prévu la prévention d'un
certain nombre de conflits d'intérêts la
loi notamment prévu qu'un site de paris
ne pouvait pas proposer de paris sur des
évènements ou sur des sociétés des clubs
qu'il contrôlait directement ou
indirectement
c'est une disposition de prévention des
conflits d'intérêts que l'arjel à
contrôler ce qui fait que trois
opérateurs ont été contraints de limiter
leur offre pour ces raisons l'opérateur
sajoo ne pas proposer de paris sur les
compétitions organisées par la filiale
du même groupe amaury qui est à etsaut
ça concerne par exemple le tour de
france où le paris dakar
l'opérateur française des jeux ne peut
pas parié ne peut pas proposer de paris
sur les compétitions cyclistes auquel
son équipe participe et il en est de
même pour l'opérateur contrôlée par tf1
s'agissant de son équipe cycliste
bouygues telecom donc cette disposition
a trouvé à s'appliquer a été contrôlée
par l'autorité de régulation l'autorisé
la loi également prévu que les
fédérations sportives devait adopter des
règlements visant à interdire aux
compétiteurs ou aux acteurs des
compétitions de parier sur ces mêmes
compétitions ses règlements pour
l'essentiel ont été adoptés par les
fédérations ou les organisateurs donc
les dispositions de la loi pour prévenir
un certain nombre de risques trouve
aujourd'hui à s'appliquer
je pense qu'il faut naturellement aller
plus loin notamment le probablement sur
le plan de la répression pénale de la
fraude sportive liées aux paris sportifs
sans doute sur le modèle de ce que les
italiens les anglais ou les espagnols
ont fait
en la matière s'agissant du retour
financier sur le sport nous avons évoqué
les 1,3 devenu 1,5 et qui deviendront 1
8 % de prélèvements au bénéfice du du
cnds je voulais dire également qu'il ya
eu un certain nombre de contrats de
partenariats qui ont été noués entre les
opérateurs des organisateurs
d'évènements ou des sociétés sportives
le montant de ces contrats de
partenariat qui sont transmis à
l'autorité de régulation ce montant
s'est élevé à 28 millions d'euros
d'ailleurs qu'il ya 28 millions d'euros
de dépenses publicitaires d'une certaine
façon au travers de ses contrats de
sponsoring partenariats qui vont au
sport et qui émane des opérateurs agréés
partie des oui c'est intégrer dans les
dépenses marketing publicitaire ça veut
dire que les les opérateurs peuvent
sponsoriser en quelque sorte des
compétiteurs oui ils le peuvent
sous deux conditions la première c'est
que l'opérateur soit agréé sinon ils
tomberaient sous le coup du délit de
publicité pour un site non agréé puisque
partenariat ou sponsoring est assimilée
à une action publicitaire et
deuxièmement les contrats de partenariat
sont transmis à l'autorité de régulation
qui doit veiller à ce qu'ils ne
s'apparente pas à une forme de contrôle
indirect par ces opérateurs des
organisateurs d'évènements ou des
sociétés sportives si le le le contrat
de venette trop déséquilibrée au regard
des autres recettes de l'organisateur ou
de la société sportive parce que ces
cétacés et si un prélèvement pour la
filière vaut bien ce que c'est mais si
l'opérateur met son argent sur l'un des
compétiteurs ça pose quand même un vrai
il peut sponsoriser les opérateurs de
paris peuvent consolider des sociétés
sportives
donc c'est la raison pour laquelle vous
avez sur les maillots d'un certain
nombre de clubs de foot le
opérateur de riespach des ce sont des
contrats commerciaux
sauf que c'est ils sont censés être
équilibré c'est à dire vous achetez une
visibilité donc toute la difficulté que
vous avez raison de souligner c'est de
s'assurer du caractère équilibré de ces
contrats et du fait que au travers de
ces contrats il n'y a pas une forme de
contrôle indirect d'exercer par
l'opérateur sur la société sportif
considéré il faut vraiment l'autorité de
l'arjel pour apprécier ce jeu c'est un
vrai sujet je le reconnais bien
volontiers
c'est un sujet que parce que vous avez
deux façons pour les opérateurs de
financer la filière ou bien ils
financent collectivement par un
prélèvement qui va à l'ensemble des
compétiteurs ou bien il met le paquet
dans un contrat de partenariat pour l'un
des compétiteurs de tous tu sais c'est
pas alternatif c'est il ya de toute
façon une fiscalité prélèvements
obligatoires pour le cnds que tous assis
sur les miss doivent payer
il y a le droit d'exploitation qui est
une obligation légale
l'opérateur de paris ne peut pas
proposer des paris sur un événement
organisé en france il n'a pas
contractualiser avec son organisateur
c'est le droit d'exploitation
et puis vous avez la publicité et la
publicité peut s'exprimer sous forme de
partenariat des deux mondes
mais c'est un vrai sujet éthique paraît
bien d'accord pour dire que si vous êtes
le coach d'une équipe de football
vous pourrez distribuer des primes aux
buts marqués en fonction des moyens dont
vous disposez tous et les moyens dont
dispose équipes dépendent alors dû
partenaires opérateurs qui le remettra
plus ou moins d'argent il ça vient
clairement recettes de la société
sportive
la question c'est de savoir si si au
travers de ses recettes publicitaires
l'opérateur influe sur la politique
sportive du club
donc c'est un sujet et c'est tellement
un sujet qu'il est d'ailleurs dans le
cadre des recommandations
que le conseil de l'europe est en train
de préparer
c'est un sujet en débat c'est un sujet
en débat en général en europe
ces actions de partenariat et de
sponsoring ne sont pas interdites par
contre je vous rejoins sur le fait que
l'appréciation de l'equilibre du contrat
et de l' influence qu au travers de ce
contrat l'opérateur peut avoir sur la
société sportive ou l'organisateur est
une question importante pour l'éthique
sportive
s'agissant je vais très vite maintenant
du contrôle les opérateurs agréés qui
est exercée par l'autorité de régulation
les opérateurs agréés ont déclaré 69 nom
de domaine qu'ils exploitent dans le
cadre de leur agrément
ce sont donc ces 69 noms de domaines qui
sont contrôlés par l'autorité de
régulation
nous avons engagé 231 actions de de
contrôle sur ces noms de domaine
quatre-vingt deux actions pré
contentieuse et contentieuses sous forme
de courrier d'injonction ou de procès
verbaux de constatation de manquement
aux obligations législatives ou
réglementaires ont été dressés par
l'autorité un certain nombre de mises en
demeure ont été adressées aux opérateurs
et 3 saisine de la commission des
sanctions ont d'ores et déjà été
effectués la commission des sanctions je
le rappelle est totalement distinct du
du collège de l'autorité de régulation
est donc cette commission des sanctions
instruit aujourd'hui
3 posté dur de sanctions sur saisine du
but du collège je vous rappelle
également qu'il ya une procédure de
certification qui est prévu par la loi à
six mois plus un an 14 certificateur ont
été inscrits sur la liste de
certificateur par l'autorité de
régulation en comparaison avec la
situation italienne
l'autorité italienne a inscrit de son
côté huit organismes certificateurs sur
sa propre liste
donc nous avons un nombre relativement
satisfaisant de certificateur et les
certificateurs des dispositifs
informatiques sont ces certifications
sont en cours
puisqu'elle devait être engagé six mois
après que que les serveurs que les
frontaux pardon soit opérationnel et
nous avons souhaité que les frontaux de
vente être totalement opérationnelle six
mois après le début de leur mise en
oeuvre
nous avons souhaité que la certification
se décale tout petit peu pour porter sur
la totalité de des fonctionnalités
d'aidé frontaux donc ces procédures de
certification sont engagés s'agissant de
la lutte contre les sites illégaux enfin
pour conclure je vous rappelle d'abord
que l'autorité de régulation n'est pas
est la seule autorité compétente en
matière de lutte contre les sites
illégaux
c'est même une compétence
complémentaires que celle de l'arjel la
compétence principale relevant des
autorités pénales l'arjel a cependant
deux procédures à sa disposition une
procédure civile c'est l'article 61 de
la loi qui nous permet en la forme des
du référé de saisir le tribunal de
grande instance pour qu'il ordonne le
blocage par les ai failli de ces sites
nous avons adressé plus de 200 mises en
demeure aux sites illégaux que nous
avons identifiés
l'essentiel de ces sites sans que la
procédure nice jusqu'au tribunal de
grande instance ont géré aux blocs et
leur site c'est à dire qu'il n'est plus
possible de s'inscrire sur leur site à
partir d'une adresse ip française ou en
déclarant et/ou en déclarant une
résidence en france nous avons obtenu
une décision de justice
à l'été 2010 s'agissant d'un site
installé à gibraltar qui n'avait pas
immédiatement j'ai oublié dans des
délais raisonnables
on son accès en france nous avons une
deuxième procédure qui est pendante et
qui sera audiencée courant mars devant
le tribunal de grande instance et nous
avons trois autres procédures qui sont
en phase ultime de des délais de mises
en demeure
je voulais également vous vous indiquer
que nous avons concentré nos efforts
dans le cadre de cette procédure civile
dans un premier temps sur les sites
illégaux poker jeux de cercles hippiques
et sportifs nous le faisons maintenant
en matière de casino en ligne en matière
de lutte contre le blanchiment l'arjel
en relation avec tracts fin à édicter
les normes complémentaires qu'en tant
qu'autorité de régulation elle devait
été dictée comme le code monétaire et
financier
lily y invitait s'agissant de la lutte
contre l'addiction
je voulais vous indiquez l'application
du fichier des interdits de jeu a été
aux jeux en ligne a été très sévèrement
contrôlés par l'autorité de régulation
et nous avons constaté que 20 % des
personnes inscrites sur le fichier des
interdits de jeu avait essayé d'ouvrir
des comptes joueurs sur des sites en
ligne ce qui veut dire que cette mesure
était souhaitable elle est efficace elle
était souhaitable parce qu'il y a toutes
raisons de penser que c'est interdit de
jouer le jeu jouait sur des sites
illégaux avant le cadre de la nouvelle
régulation
nous avons également contrôler très
strictement
l'obligation de proposer des modèles
pour s'en sortir dit je savais qu'on
vient de là combien l'interdît dieu il y
à peu il y à un peu moins de 40 milles
interdits de jeux sur sur le fichier
mais ce qui est important c'est que ce
sont des gens qui se sont pour
l'essentiel auto interdits de jeu c'est
à dire des gens qui ont connu de vrais
problèmes d'addiction et donc on
constate que 20 % d'entre eux qui ont
dans le cadre d'une démarche volontaire
demandé à être interdits de casinos
essayait de jouer sur des sites de paris
en ligne qu'il fallait vraiment les
aider à se protéger contre contre
l'addiction les modérateurs de jeux ont
été contrôlés la valeur médiane du
modérateur de dépôt maximum est établi à
1000 euros la valeur médiane du
modérateur de mise maximum constater
puisque c'est un auto modérateur est à
10000 euros
la ligne à d'alice le numéro vert pour
assister les joueurs en difficulté a
reçu au 21 décembre
il est géré par l'inpes près de 12000
appel mais seulement 23 % de ces appels
concernent des joueurs difficulté
l'essentiel des appels concernait en
réalité le service après-vente des
opérateurs les joueurs ils ont confondu
le numéro de link face au numéro 2 avec
le numéro 2 de sav des opérateurs
voilà monsieur le président je m'en
tiens là si monsieur le président pour
ce compte rendu très complet des
activités est que vous avez développé
depuis la promulgation de la loi
je vais demander au revoir au général
s'il a une question à vous poser
monsieur le président le président
vilotte a développé beaucoup d'aspects
en partie qu'en ce qui concerne les
activités de la commission des sanctions
et la prévention des conflits d'intérêt
et qui auraient pu faire l'objet de
questions mais il y a été répondu par
avance et du moins dans la partie de
l'exposé que j'ai pu entendre et j'ai
une seule question à poser sur le
président au delà du rôle d'agrément du
rôle répressif le cas échéant de l'arjel
et vous êtes en mesure d'observer et
cette profession
cette activité est ma question est de
connaître votre appréciation votre
diagnostic sur l'évolution de cette
branche d'activité des prestataires de
paris
depuis la mise en place de l'arjel et
avez-vous des considérations à nous
livrer en particulier sur les nouveaux
marchés que s'efforce de prospecter le
pmu je serais heureux que vous puissiez
nous apportez votre expertise votre
jugement sur ce sujet et d'autre part
est-ce que l'ouverture finalement éteint
la est à la largeur des attentes si
j'ose ainsi m'exprimer est-ce que
l'ouverture que l'on attendait avec la
loi et la mise en place du régulateur
s'est bien produite et quelle
appréciation portez vous en résumé sur
l'évolution du paysage c'est être un
complément et prolongement de cette
question
est ce qu'il n'ya pas nécessité pour les
opérateurs de se regrouper parce que on
voit bien que le déchaînement les
dépenses de marketing et publicité très
lourd sur la gestion est ce qu'on va
pouvoir maintenir autant d'opérateurs
cela mon interrogation
je pense que ce que nous avons constaté
en 2010 est somme toute assez normal
s'agissant d'un marché qui s'ouvre est à
la concurrence avec des acteurs qui
entrent sur ce marché qui essaye d'y
acquérir des parts de marché
significatives et qui accompagne cette
entrée sur le marché de l'e plan
publicitaire et marketing un niveau très
élevé
je pense donc que le marché va très
rapidement évoluer qu'un certain nombre
d'opérateurs vont disparaître qu'il y
aura des opérations de rachat
d'opérateurs par deux plus gros
opérateurs et que nous aurons
progressivement un nombre d'opérateurs
en tout cas sur le marché des paris
sportifs et sur le marché du poker en
ligne
keira en diminution et le marché et ont
connu donc ce resserrement probablement
effectivement on assistera à une
diminution des frais publicitaires et
marketing et peut-être à une politique
des prix plus fine qui se s'exprimera au
travers des stratégies de trj et de
cotes pour les paris à cotes fixes
donc je pense comme vous que ce que nous
avons constaté en 2010 est somme toute
normal sont un marché qui s'ouvre à la
concurrence et que ce que nous allons
être amenés à constater c'est un
resserrement du nombre d'opérateurs et
c'est donc des politiques plus
différenciée da proche des consommateurs
avec des instruments comme le trj et la
stratégie de cotes pour répondra aux
préoccupations de monsieur rapportera je
crois qu'il faut vraiment que l'on
raisonne les trois marches et
distinctement aujourd'hui je ne fais pas
de prospective trop lointaine
si je devais simplifiée et vous
m'excuserez de cette simplification
s'agissant du marché hippiques très
clairement c'est un marché fort peu
concurrentiel aujourd'hui
et donc c'est un sujet qui relève plus
de l'autorité de la concurrence que de
l'autorité de régulation des jeux en
ligne et il y à un sujet fondamental
pour le marché des paris hippiques qui
doit être réglé pour que le marché
puisse se développer sans arrière pensée
c'est le retour filière est donc le
débat qui est engagé aujourd'hui par les
autorités françaises avec la commission
européenne pour trouver un fondement
juridique à la taxe affectée ou à toute
forme de retour filière que ce soit à la
mode britannique
une forme de droits d'exploitation dont
le prix est administré par l'état
ce débat là est un débat central
évidemment pour la filière et je pense
qu'il conditionne d'une certaine façon
ensuite l'exercice d'un jeu plus
concurrentiel dans le secteur cette
question du retour aux filières trop et
à la filière gallo étant réglé et
aujourd'hui il n'est pas juridiquement
stabiliser la surprise dans le secteur
des paris hippiques
c'est qu'il y à une demande très forte
ça nous le savions en matière de deep is
mans france mais qu'elle trouve très
facilement à s'exprimer sur internet ce
qui était sans doute assez négligent et
on pensait que le parieurs hippiques du
par hull son profil son âge son son
niveau csp serait moins attirés par
l'internet que le parieur sportif ou que
le joueur de poker ça n'est pas vrai il
est très présent sur internet et le
montant des paris hippiques sur internet
tend à se développer
le pari sportif
très vive concurrence on a évoqué vous
l'avez évoqué le paysage d'entrée les
évolutions probablement attendre je
pense que le pari sportif quand même
c'est un pari c'est un secteur avec un
modèle économique tout à fait spécifique
le modèle économique de la cote et donc
je pense qu'il y ait un vrai débat sur
les instruments fiscaux ou des
instruments de de contrôle notamment du
trj dans ce secteur spécifique des paris
hippiques des paris sportifs et je pense
qu'au delà de la diminution qu'on doit
attendre naturellement du volume des
dépenses publicitaires et marketing
il y a quand même là un sujet de modèle
économique
s'agissant du marché du poker est un jeu
de répartition comme une certaine façon
le le mutuelle là je pense qu'il faut
que nous réfléchissions notamment dans
la cause de la clause de revoyure ou aux
instruments parfaitement adaptée de
lutte contre l'addiction
parce que nous avons un marché qui est
un marché qui se développe très vite
avec un nombre de joueurs extrêmement
important et probablement il ya des
modérateurs de jeu qu'il faudra sans
doute imposer
je donne un exemple le législateur a été
extrêmement attentif à l'occasion des
débats à ce que un parieur ne puisse pas
perdre plus qu'il n'avait imaginé
perdent c'est la raison pour laquelle on
a interdit le pari à fourchette dans le
secteur des paris sportifs
or dans le poker si vous n'interdisez
pas la possibilité de ré alimenter votre
compte
pendant la session de jeu vous ne savez
pas quel sera le montant maximum de vos
pairs et donc qu'on puisse jouer avec
son dépôt parce qu'on le connaît et on
sait qu'au pire on va tout perdre
c'est une chose pouvoir réalimenter en
session dans cours de la session de jeu
son compte ça pose un problème éventuel
mandat d'addiction et de contrôle donc
je pense que dans le secteur du poker
il y a des problèmes de modérateurs de
jeu
a étudié pour être parfaitement adapté à
la spécificité du jeu de poker
il y aura également le président comme
en matière de paris sportifs des
opérateurs qui disparaîtront des
opérateurs qui se restructurent on est
un trj qui viendra à diminuer évidemment
merci la parole est maintenant aux
rapporteurs très très spécial et experts
très spécial françois trucy
merci monsieur le président 6 2 je vais
essayer de base être égoïste et de poser
une ou des questions qui sont surtout
susceptible d'intéresser les les membres
de la commission parce que pour le reste
c'est un travail constant que nous
pratiquons ensemble et que auquel je
tiens beaucoup
mais si vous me permettez monsieur le
président d'abord deux appréciations
premièrement je pas là pour défendre les
options gouvernementales dans la loi il
y en a au moins une qui était
extrêmement importante c'est la création
purement et simplement d'une autorité de
régulation indépendante alors même que
ce processus de gestion de régulation
n'est pas forcément bien vu au parlement
qui a l'impression que chaque fois le
l'état se dessaisit d'une puissance ce
n'est pas le cas dans le dans la
création de l'arjel qui est vraiment
l'expression de la puissance publique
tels qu' ici qu'on soit jacobins où ou
moins jacobins et paraît tout à fait
nécessaire
d'autre part autre élément
d'appréciation positif c'est que par
rapport justement une gestion directe
des services de tel ou tel ministère la
réactivité de l'arjel nous garantit
premièrement de devoir gérer un domaine
extrêmement compliqué extrêmement riche
en rebondissements en évolution est donc
là la réactivité d'une autorité
indépendante nous paraît essentiel pour
lol pour l'avenir même s'il des
perfectionnements sont toujours
souhaitable bien entendu deuxième
initiative intéressante à l'époque c'est
la préfiguration parce qu'en définitive
coupe du monde ou pas l'arjel a été en
fait mis en place sous la forme d'une
pudique d'une préfiguration qui lui
permettait de totalement opérationnel
dès la première
sur la loi ce qui est quand même un
point extrêmement positif et donc qui
amena permis en définitive que le la loi
commence à s'appliquer dans les
meilleures conditions possibles
ce qui n'est pas forcément le cas quand
il faut attendre des multitudes de
décret d'application est là et pour
donner un exemple de l'apathie
administrative que l'arjel ne ne montre
pas encore c'est que pour le colloque du
22 mars consacré à l'ensemble des
problèmes de jeu en ligne ou pas le la
direction générale de la santé refuse de
venir au colloque sous prétexte que le
colloque est comme tous les colosses
partiellement financée par les
opérateurs y compris par les opérateurs
d'état comme la française des jeux et
qu'ils jettent hausse absolument
inadmissible d'admissibles ou la
direction générale de la santé ne sais
pas quoi dire encore de ce qu'est
laquelle a dû faire pendant un an
pratiquement ou alors elles se réfugient
derrière des mauvais arguments nous
n'attendons pas cela de l'arjel au
contraire sa réactivité positive
le monsieur vilotte plusieurs questions
les études ciblées que vous avez lancé
comme ici une partie de vos missions
la plus importante est elle pas celle
qui va consister à cerner le ce fameux
trj taux de retour aux joueurs parce
qu'en définitive on voit bien que dans
la clause de revoyure les opérateurs
tout le monde va arriver avec des
questions très précises
comment alléger la fiscalité comment
améliorer le trj qui est un facteur
concurrentiel alors même que sur le
fameux taux de retour l'état les
gouvernements à l'époque a dit je ne
veux pas que le trj soit sur soi
meilleur parce que j'estime que si un
taux de retour propre important c'est un
facteur d'addiction au jeu c'est à dire
plus depuis nam en plus l'on peut gagner
puis l'ont peut être incité à jouer donc
plus on risque de flatter la diction
avec ce qui est la 2
de mauvais or nous savons très bien que
des psychiatres sur ce sujet ne sont pas
d'accord il y en a qui pensent que le
trj est un facteur addictif et d'autres
qu'ils ne sont pas et de ce côté là et
qu'est ce que vous pensez pouvoir nous
donner le moment venu en matière de
réponse je vous avais parlé très bien la
répression des rappelant pour les
collègues
dès que cette loi ne peut pas réussir
les agréments ne peuvent pas réussir
s'il n'y a pas une répression
extrêmement efficace de tout ce qui
reste dans le secteur il légaliser pas
facile et de ce côté là est ce que vous
avez trouvé auprès de ceux qui vous aide
il y compris la justice tout toute la
coopération pouces métier et enfin
dernier point me suis un peu perplexe
devant les travaux de l'afnor et dans le
domaine des jeux je sais pas du tout ce
qu'on peut en demain il trouvé comme
aide supplémentaire à l'encadrement du
jeu et enfin dernière question parce que
je vois que vous n'avez pas réagi
négativement à la saisine de l'autorité
de la concurrence dans ce domaine là or
les questions en matière de concurrence
entre eux les justement les grands
opérateurs historiques et les nouveaux
opérateurs en ligne
c'est un sujet qui sera sûrement au
coeur de la clause de revoyure les
autres questions de nos collègues
membres de la commission car nous nous
sommes attendant une dans une contrainte
chronologique très très serré marie
hélène des esgaulx
oui monsieur président merlus le vif de
20000 habitants ayant une casino ma
question concernait bien sur la
fiscalité de ces jeux en ligne revenons
aux collectivités locales
alors le législateur avait prévu une
compensation pour les villes ayant une
casino je note que nous n'avons rien
reçu à ce jour que une prévision donc
est faite de 6 millions d'euros sur le
poker pour 2010 permettez moi de vous
dire que ce monde dans et est très
faible à mes yeux
au regard des quelques 300 casino que
nous avons
mais sur ces pagnes rec 2 2 une règle de
trois qui sera fait mais j'imagine que
ce sera fait avec en fonction des
recettes de chaque casino une espèce de
prorata on n'en seriez encore
aujourd'hui et je pense aussi qu'il
faudrait clarifier les conditions de
rémunération pour une casino qui devient
lui-même opérateurs de jeux en ligne ce
qui est déjà le cas à ma connaissance et
y compris pour le mienne d'ailleurs
voilà c'était plus pour que ça soit acté
parce que vous aviez déjà posé la
question de ce président merci marie
hélène frochot marque
merci monsieur le président je remercie
monsieur vilotte des renseignements 13
fournie très détaillé qui nous a porté
sur ce sujet
j'étais le porte parole de notre groupe
au moment de l'adoption du texte et vous
savez qu'on n'a pas forcément partagé
toute la philosophie sous jacente en ce
qui concerne ce texte qui nous a été
soumis et la question que pose et le
président arthuis tout à l'heure c'était
la légalisation est elle un succès donc
moi de ce point de vue je voulais vous
interroger sur est-ce un succès du point
de vue de ce qui était l'un des
objectifs fondamentaux la disparition
progressive des sites illégaux
est-ce qu'on a des indications précises
à dessus s'agissant du développement du
jeu et de l'effet de la publicité qui
aujourd'hui légalisés est-ce qu'on a une
indication sur l'impact cette publicité
à grande échelle qui aujourd'hui
légalisés est-ce que ça a effectivement
eu un effet de démultiplication des
actes de jeu dans l'autre pays
on a évoqué le point d'équilibré tout à
l'heure sur la fiscalité mais je paye y
revenir ce serait trop long sans doute
je voulais simplement dire que ce texte
a été adopté en urgence et un point nous
avons dénoncé à l'époque il y avait
urgence parce qu'elle est la coupe du
monde de foot et qu'il fallait aller
vite
de ce point de vue nous avons sentiment
que nous avions vu juste parce qu'il ya
quand même eu beaucoup de choses qui ont
été dites depuis et qui ont démontré que
on avait un peu bricolé les choses si je
puis me permettre cette expression
aujourd'hui le le coup le comité
consultatif des jeux de la célérité
le comité consultatif des jeux a mis
beaucoup de temps à émerger
monsieur trucy ne me démentira pas sur
ce point
ça a mis du temps à émerger françois le
centre de soins pour joueur excessif n'a
pas les financements toujours neuf mois
après le vote de la loi
l'addiction a été considéré qu vraiment
le parent pauvre dans cette mise en
route de ce dispositif
et quant à l'autorité de la concurrence
elle s'interroge sur la régulation du
prix du droit où paris est ainsi que
l'arjel a trouvé une solution de
régulation donc on voit bien que le vote
du texte s'est fait dans la
précipitation et que sur ces trois
sujets au moins on n'avait pas préparé
le terrain alors qu'il ya véritablement
des exigences majeures
enfin en ce qui concerne l'éthique du
sport j'ai été confronté il ya quelques
jours à un président de fédération
française
kim indiqué qu'il était très inquiet
quand aujourd'hui aux sollicitations qui
sont faites à certains joueurs parfois
même dans les vestiaires on vient
essayer de les convaincre d'avoir tel
comportement dans l'air de jeu
avez vous le sentiment que il ya des
dérapages significatif et qu' il ya
quelque chose à faire sans doute pour
protéger les joueurs face à ces
tentations très lourde et enfin dernier
point de ce président je crois que c'est
important pour notre commission des
finances mais je crains que monsieur
miled n'est pas les chiffres
lorsqu'ils concernent les rentrées
fiscales l'ancien dispositif lié au jeu
rapportés en france quelque chose comme
5 milliards d'euros de prélèvements est
rentrée de toutes sortes
on ne sait pas aujourd'hui ce qui va en
aide nos propres calculs nous conduisent
à penser que nous étions peu près à une
perte de 2 milliards de recettes avec le
les nouveaux taux appliqués qui étaient
en baisse sensiblement
donc est-ce que vous avez quelques
indications en ce qui concerne les
évolutions des rentrées fiscales pour le
budget de l'état et l'ensemble des
prélèvements qui lui sont associés
ainsi thé revenant françois fortassin
merci monsieur le président de questions
de très brèves
la première c'est pour savoir s'il entre
dans votre champ d'action le fait que
les jeux ça peut être quand même un
système de recyclage de largeur de
l'argent sale
est ce que vous avez à ce niveau des
moyens de vérifier cela est le deuxième
point quand on voit la façon dont
certaines coupes du monde va être
attribué un pays comme le qatar
on peut se demander s'il n'ya pas selon
l'expression consacrée des enveloppes
qui circule même parmi les plus hautes
autorités du football et aux formes
moi je dirais que si les jambes ont
essayé de soudoyer les joueurs ou
d'avoir des pressions sur les joueurs
ce sont des amateurs les enfants de
choeur c'est tellement plus facile
d'intervenir sur un arbitre il ya un
sport que je connais aussi bien que le
président françois trucy qui est le
rugby on sait très bien qu'un arbitre
qui met à la porte un joueur pour dix
minutes et il a 25 occasions dans le
match de le faire il faut
systématiquement le résultat alors est
ce que il entre dans mon char de
l'application de vous intéresser à ces
problèmes
larbitre suprême c'est l'arjel monsieur
le président s'il vous plaît et vous
avez été choisi pour vos qualités
éminentes
si vous pouviez répondre cinq minutes à
l'ensemble des intervenants ce serait
formidable
j'essaye d'aller très vite monsieur le
sénateur trucy s'agissant du taux de
retour aux joueurs
ce que nous constatons incontestablement
aujourd'hui c'est que lorsque l'on
diminue le taux de retour aux joueurs
cela un effet
immédiat sur le volume des paris
enregistrés alors c'est encore une fois
donc on joue alors problèmes d'addiction
c'est qu'on joue sur la confusion entre
une moyenne collective et une chance
individuel de gains si on affiche un trj
élevé on a le sentiment que ça
s'applique à chacun d'entre nous or ça
n'est naturellement pas le cas c'est en
ce sens là que ça peut être un
instrument addictif
ça a un effet sur le volume de paris la
question c'est est-ce que cet effet
positif on limite le volume et donc la
diction est ce que cet effet négatif
c'est à dire que les joueurs mettant en
concurrence et en surveillant
l'attractivité des sites se réoriente
vers des dispositifs illégaux ou alors
là pour le coup ils ne sont absolument
pas protégés donc nous avons lancé au
titre de la première de nos commissions
une étude pour apprécier le comportement
des joueurs notamment en relation avec
cette question sur le plan pénal
je dois dire que monsieur le président
les dispositions que la loi a prévu
notamment d' échanges d'informations
entre le parquet et et l'autorité de
régulation ne sont pas des dispositions
aujourd'hui suffisamment efficace et
l'arjel n'a que peu de renseignements
peu d'informations en provenance des
procédures pénales
le parquet ayant une lecture de ces deux
dispositions extrêmement limités et donc
nous peinons à correctement articulé
l'action civile qui est la nôtre
l'action administrative qui est la nôtre
et l'action pénale qui relèvent des
services de police judiciaire sous le
contrôle du parquet donc je crois pour
faire simple il ya là un sujet de
revoyure son sang sont sans nul doute
l'afnor le danger monsieur le rapporteur
c'est perçu par nous c'est un alignement
vers le bas des normes de régulation et
de contrôle des opérateurs
nous ne nous sommes pas associés à la
démarche de l'afnor parce qu'il ne nous
a pas semblé que c'était le rôle d'une
autorité de régulation
donc nous nous la condamnons pas
mais attention est ce que ça ne
traduisent pas un alignement vers le bas
l'autorité de la concurrence je crois
que c'est par contre extrêmement
intéressant de voir comment une autorité
sectorielle peut-être un peu travailler
avec l'autorité de la concurrence
donc nous avons beaucoup échangé sur ces
questions de concurrence
nous avons été très attentifs à l'avis
de l'autorité de la concurrence
c'est un avis assez rare puisque c'est
une autosaisine c'est un avis je pense
que les opérateurs ont naturellement un
intérêt à attirer toutes les
conséquences de ce qui à ce stade n'est
qu'un avis mais qui dans le cadre
d'éventuels contentieux pourrait devenir
contraignants pour pour le très
attention quand même parce que j'aurai
tôt fait de casser une filière jeu c'est
pour ça que la question centrale
monsieur le président pour moi c'est le
retour filière c'est réglant cette
question là parce qu'elle conditionne
absolument tout le reste
règle 11 et tant qu'elle n'est pas réglé
j'ai à dire restons en l'état la
question que vous m'avez posé madame la
fiscalité c'est pas la faire de larges
et souhaitez vous donner des des chiffes
d'extrapolation fiscal à partir du
montant des mises
mais nous ne sommes pas les services
fiscaux par contre je vous confirme que
à peu près tous les casinos soit
collectivement soit individuellement
sont devenus des opérateurs de poker en
ligne et et qu' il semblerait mais c'est
à apprécier dans le temps que
l'engouement pour le poker en ligne
puisse avoir des effets bénéfiques pour
le poker en dur en salle il ya un
problème
ensuite pour les casinotiers qui
consiste à capter cette cette demande et
faire en sorte qu'elles le soient
satisfaites
y compris par une offre en dur monsieur
le sénateur françois marc plusieurs
d'abord le succès ou l'insuccès ça fait
écho aux propos introductif d'ailleurs
du président a recueilli le succès ça
n'aurait pas été de constater que les
paris sportifs se serait fait
enregistrer trois ou quatre milliards de
mise
donc l'objectif c'était de faire
basculer significativement la demande de
l'offre illégale vers
offre légale les chiffres aussi bien en
paris sportifs paris hippiques sont à
peu près en ligne avec ce que nous
savions du marché illégal et du marché
les gars paris sportifs on estimait
entre 900 et 1 milliard d'euros -5% le
du fait de l'opérateur légal qui était
la française des jeux
nous sommes à peu près en ligne avec ce
volume ça veut dire que je pense que
très significativement l'offre a basculé
vers les opérateurs légaux que la
publicité n'a pas eu un effet en tout
cas pour les paris sportifs et les paris
hippiques d'explosions et l'inflation de
la demande ce qui n'aurait pas été
souhaitable
je pense que les sites illégaux sont
devenus marginaux je ne dis pas qu'il
n'en existe plus je pense qu'ils sont
devenus marginaux et que par voie de
conséquence sur ses sites illégaux les
procédures pénales civile ou
administrative peut retrouver leur
efficacité mais c'est un problème
d'équilibré et donc il faut veiller à
c'est cet équilibre et je pense que la
bonne monnaie exceptionnellement ayant
chassé une part importante de la
mauvaise maintenant il faut faire
attention à des comportements de
mauvaise foi de contournement de la loi
qui fait appel à un accord
intentionnelle entre le joueur et le
site
et est ce que les cils point com qui
sont géo bloqués en france n'ont pas mis
en place des dispositifs d'accueil de
gros joueurs qui sont des dispositifs
masqué qui ne peuvent être démasqué que
par les procédures pénales
le financement dès que ça pas monsieur
le sénateur je vous rejoins je l' ai
déjà dit d'ailleurs publiquement
il y a dans la loi un dispositif de
prélèvement au bénéfice de l'assurance
maladie dont le législateur il a dit
qu'il devait notamment permettre le
financement des centres de 2,2 de prise
en charge des joueurs addictifs je pense
qu'il est souhaitable hautement
souhaitable que cette disposition
puisque l'argent est là trouve à
s'appliquer qu'il y ait des accords
entre la caisse nationale d'assurance
maladie et ses centres de prise en
charge des joueurs addictifs donc je
pense qu'il la loi est bonne il faut
l'appliquer
mais la disposition existe le droit au
pari
je pense que c'est un instrument
absolument fondamental de
responsabiliser
juridique de l'acteur qui est
l'organisateur de l'événement sportif je
pense qu'en matière de lutte contre les
risques de corruption
c'est un instrument absolument
indispensable absolument lundi soir
d'ailleurs je suis frappé de ce que y
compris le cio qui était plutôt
interrogatif sur cette disposition par
la voix de son président considère que
c'est une disposition dont il se réjouit
que la commission ne n'ai rien trouvé à
redire
je pense que c'est souhaitable que cette
disposition demeure c'est un prix qui
est difficile à trouver puisqu'il a pas
d'exclusivité
par contre je ne rejoins pas l'autorité
de la concurrence pour moi ça ne peut
pas être un prix administrés parce que
il doit prendre en considération
notamment le coût de prévention des
risques mais seulement notamment et tout
le reste c'est la valeur de l'événement
donc je pense que nous sommes à six mois
il est normal que les organisateurs les
opérateurs aient eu un peu de mal à se
retrouver
l'éthique clairement bien sur l'éthique
sportive et ça fait un lien avec
l'intervention de monsieur le sénateur
fortassin évidemment l'éthique sportive
c'est quelque chose absolument
fondamental je les ai indiqué c'est pas
seulement surveiller les paris
enregistré de francs c'est surveillé
monitorer l'ensemble des paris sur des
événements et je crois qu'il y à des
mesures complémentaires à prendre qui ne
relèvent pas simplement de la régulation
des jeux et paris et la ministre des
sports madame jouanno m'a d'ailleurs
demandé de lui remettre sur cette
question un rapport que je lui remettrai
à la mi mars et qui ne suggère des
mesures complémentaires aussi bien au
plan national qu'au plan international
pour lutter contre ce fléau qui me
paraît réellement être un
un fléau et le risque est extrêmement
élevé il l'est je pense à l'occasion de
paris qui ne sont pas enregistrés auprès
d'opérateurs agréés l'essentiel quand on
constate que sur des matchs de foot de
ligue 2 il ya plus de paris en asie
qu'il n'y en a en france des matchs en
france est un problème sauf les si les
asiatiques ont ont pris plus que nous
conscience de la qualité de notre duke 2
mais autrement il ya un sujet qui n'est
pas là donc je suis un sujet fondamental
mais il a un petit 5 de la compétence de
l'arjel c'est la raison pour laquelle je
formulerai des propositions à la
ministre des sports dans peu de temps
sur ce sujet à sa demande le blanchiment
cette question sport rejoignant la
question le blanchiment dessus le
sénateur oui il appartient à l'arjel de
contrôler que les opérateurs de perdrix
qui sont assujettis à la directive
anti-blanchiment en respectent bien
leurs obligations notamment de
déclarations de soupçons sont que nous
travaillons en relation constante avec
maxime
nous avons édicté récemment relâché avec
la direction du trésor et tracfin des
normes qui sont spécifiquement appliquer
aux opérateurs de paris pour prévenir
les opérations de blanchiment
donc c'est un sujet extrêmement
important nous sommes en train de
recevoir les premiers rapports
d'ailleurs deux des opérateurs sur les
actions qu'ils ont été amenés à conduire
en matière de lutte contre le
blanchiment
voici monsieur le président audition est
intéressante qui permettra à françois
trucy d'exercer ses autres
responsabilités et chacun d'entre nous
de préparer la clause de revoyure
et ce rendez vous du 15 novembre
prochain
monsieur le président nous comptons sur
vous pour que les opérateurs ne soient
pas des prédateurs
je pense aux filières que la défense des
parieurs ne conduisent pas à la
disparition des filières sur lesquels
les jeux sont pris c'est la fin de cette
audition merci à vous de l'avoir suivi
très bonne journée à tous sur public
sénat